encore là demain soir tant que reporter
paysagiste portraitiste photographe de
mode et en 40 ans tu as fait à peu près
six mille photos
oui je ne sais pas j'ai fait ce que j'ai
fait 400 500 photos que je suis vraiment
très voilà
[Applaudissements]
et
mais
tu es surtout l'inventeur du reportage
de mode c'est à dire que c'est toi qui a
débarrassé la photo de mode du studio et
fort de son expérience dans le reportage
tutu a fait des faux documents en fait
c'est à dire des amis des filles comme
ça au milieu d'une sortie de métro c'est
toi tu as inventé ça pour ça oui et nous
a l'air de rien j'ai cru et j'ai cru
d'avoir une wii a dénommé martin quelque
chose d'avoir fait mon cas qui l'a
retrouvée bien avant moi mais il est
surtout plus tard et d'ailleurs en ce
moment et organise une exposition de lui
assez bien tu es honnête moindre des
choses alors tu es né dans un village
italien qui est devenu le scénario
établi maintenant alors ta mère bon et
et comme tu dis petit rondelette plus
intéressés par les par les idées que que
par l'image que par l'apparence ses
castings analystes aussi et c'est
peut-être ça qui t'a donné cette
attirance pour les très jolies femmes en
fait non oui j'ai toujours été un peu
obsédé
l'histoire se passe à se tasser
heureusement avant ce moment ils furent
ce en ce moment ça s'est bien passé je
m'occupe de quelque chose d'encore plus
sexy qui sont les sculptures de degas
alors je passe mes journées à disputer
alors tu as été d'abord graphiste je
crois dans la publicité à milan et puis
un jour tu pars à florence avec une amie
et tu fais cette photo avec le cheval là
qui est quand même le tu dis qu'il est
ressorti longtemps après ah oui je
m'exile compte de rien c'est symbolique
d'une révolution enfin oui mais alors
j'en avais pas le moindre relais j'ai
fait ça par d'autres choses que j'aurais
honte de montrer c'est après quarante
ans après que je réglais ça et puis
tiens j'avais déjà en tête et tu avais
un appareil cette 1re les cordes etc
c'est vrai que tu as vendu une
collection de timbres pour acheter sa
bein oui mon père était très
collectionneur de timbres amendes à une
collection de timbres et qui ne
m'intéressait pas du tout et
donc j'ai acheté un appareil photo mais
pas prêt avec mes photos je faisais la
même chose qu'avec les timbres c'est
dire je n'étais pas content de mes
photos alors je les coupe est plus petit
que plus petit qu'un timbre et je
connais ça sur un album parce qu'il y
avait les sous pour faire des
agrandissements
rien ne se perd oui entre perth et c2c
ça vraiment pris la place mais la police
c'est une photo qui a été publié dans un
journal italien cela pèse l'illustration
italiana wii et qui n'ont cet apparent
du ciel elle m'enfin c'est une photo
historique d'une certaine façon
après coup aujourd'hui ça fait partie de
l'histoire américaine
alors après il est allé voir cartier
bresson à paris qu'est ce qui s'est
passé vraiment rêve était de faire car
tout est maintenant et je me faisais des
et cartier-bresson ça c'est un grand
monsieur recevait les jeunes
photographes tous les mardis mercredis
et une première photo il regardait à
lambert pour ne pas être influencé par
de contenu mais par la composition se
tenait dans son système
moi j'en étais un peu une série ont
regardé mes photos à l'envers merveille
et il m'a dit plusieurs choses que je
n'ai pas compris je ne comprenais pas je
ne comprenais rien aliens sauf que
cartier bresson m'a fait sentir que la
photographie était était quelque chose
de qui pouvait aller très loin
ouais donc il m'a transmis ce sentiment
plus que de me donner des préceptes des
idées et engagé de comprendre
comprenez vraiment pas grand chose à la
tesi tu es beaucoup à cette époque-là
d'hésiter entre la photo de reportage
parce que c'est vrai que c'était un
sujet glorieux et puis la photo de mode
pour laquelle j'avais un certain mépris
finalement oui j'ai hésité tu as
vraiment j'avais envie de faire des
reportages de partir n'importe quoi je
faisais de la mode surtout parce que
j'avais besoin d'argent
ouais c'est ça et puis aussi le charme
des étés de moselle évidemment et après
il y a eu une période où est le besoin
d'argent et le l'intérêt pour le de
moselle sont devenus plus forts
oui mais aussi où les reportages de vie
plus faible dans le reportage 2000 moins
intéressant parce que tu aimais bien tu
disais dans la photo c'était les voyages
la reconnaissance et les femmes
c'est vrai que c'était des raisons
objectives mais c'est très pragmatique
par finalement ça a été influencé par
william plein pour faire de la photo de
mode parce que toi tu vas sentiment de
déchets en vis-à-vis de ça non je lis
après parce que comme face à un moment
j'ai commencé à faire de la photo de
mode mais aussi celle ci
maintenant alors c'était des cessions
dans la vie qui est rire qu'on a désiré
longtemps un terrain désertique c'est
trop tard dans les innovations que tu as
apporté il y avait effectivement l'idée
de faire du reportage de mode puis avait
aussi le 24 36 parce que à l'époque pour
faire des photos comme ça dans la rue
tout ça personne l'utiliser 24 36 et les
directeurs de fabrication dans l'est
dans les journaux il gueulait quand on
annulait du relais il trouve que c'est
impossible et
je me souviens surtout quand on a
commencé pour la publicité à faire des
affiches 24 ans 4 sél et jean par 84 37
à 24 alors au début c'est le directeur
de fabrication du jardin des modes qui a
hurlé et puis ça s'est très bien passé
après c'était suite de l apr ès et
essuie de bugs et robert brazza en
amérique tout le monde entier a accepté
de les tout petits formats de départ
quoi tu fais un autre bouquin déjà fait
s'appelle entrevue alors là c'est pas
tous contre tous c'est un bouquin
interview comment ça t'es venue cette
idée
et bah c'est finalement un reportage sur
sur la photographie j'ai sur le côté
droit j'avais envie de dire quelque
chose sur le côté je rectifie hésité
longtemps je voulais écrire un essai et
puis l'idée d'un fme n'était pas assez
sûr de moi de mon écriture
et puis je me suis dit que la plupart
des photographes que j'admire été aussi
des amis donc les gens avec lesquels je
voulais bien trop merci et c'est tout ce
que les interviews céder les rencontres
quoi il ya quatorze rencontres on se dit
ah il ya doisneau il ya newton ya sarah
moon witkin faveur de booba et vous
parler boutique c'est un pensez quoi
qu'est ce que t'en quel plus grand
dénominateur commun
de toutes ces rencontres avec ses
héritiers énorme photo là je crois que
c'est l'instant je peux je crois que
c'est la relation avec l'instant et
c'est le mystère de de la signification
de vigilance c'est la virole en ce
moment je suis en train de regarder ni
vieilles photos pour en faire une
exposition
donc je revois des milliers des dizaines
de milliers d'un stand saisir l'instant
parce que ça et oui mais il ya tous ces
instants qui est son passé sans que je
photographie il ya tous ces instants de
son passé où je fais des mauvaises
photos ou de photos sans intérêt et puis
il ya quelques instants qui reste qu'on
a grandi que tout le monde regarde qui
sont conservés et qui qui symbolise qui
représente tous les autres instances
n'ont pas été conservés c'était une
c'est effectivement de l'agression avait
dominé le temps finalement d'avoir pu
comme ça j'avais d'armement yahoo de
dominer en même temps de tuer c'est à
dire c'est aussi une forme de 2,2
deux morts c'est en fait voilà depuis
six mois et je vis vraiment des moments
très intenses mais aussi très dur avec
une planche de surf
et si tu devais donner une définition de
la photographie du directoire une pause
je peux donner une définition d'une
bonne photographie une bande
photographie d'une photocopie ou qu'on
peut faire refaire un
et quand tu dis la photographie c'est
l'art de ne pas presser le bouton ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que pour les
obtenir ces bonnes très tôt graphie ils
font refuser vokoun a très bien
l'accord il faut savoir ce qu'on refuse
c'est bien c'est à dire quand il dit il
faut il faut regarder et dire non ça ce
n'est pas un 100 m à noter que je
cherche ça ce n'est pas encore ça
jusqu'au moment où c'est ça et si on me
les donne une définition de toi moi j'en
ai bavé parker d en avoir
non je ne reconnais pas porter non
respire le magazine
oui c'est moi qui l'inventé c est humain
peut il est un peu sorti de mes mains je
voulais pas je l'avais dis parce que je
trouvais ça drôle et puis on l'a utilisé
en le prenant peut tout à fait sérieuse
à cause du cadrage et que tu pouvais en
fait c'est ça au départ dont sais pas ce
que tu disais aux mannequins qui
écoutait pas ce que tu leur disais au
cadrage le couperait la tête non c'est
ça ou non mais c'était surtout parce que
j'étais terriblement intransigeance qui
avait très mauvaise réputation encore et
la réputation de faire pleurer les
mannequins désespérée des rédactrices de
martyriser les maquilleuses ainsi de
suite et vous avez cette mauvaise
réputation parce que ce qu'elle est et
magna s'est défini leur manière mais
j'avais une idée j'ai été très
intransigeant être aussi gens et puis un
moment j'ai poussé sa au point où quand
je n'aimais pas une tête d'une si je
l'avais cadres et employés passent à
fait
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu